if you have that thing in you whatever
that is to want to start a business the
longer you wait thinking that you're
getting gaining invaluable experience
the more your life is like crystallizing
into a thing and you have a mortgage and
you have you know kids maybe and you
have all these things that actually do
make the risk you're taking a bigger
risk and I just think you know that this
idea of like oh you know you I just
think you've got to go for it early like
if you're going to do it do it as early
as you possibly can that's not say you
can't do it later and obviously if
you've got a great job and you built up
a big nest egg and that that's a whole
different conversation
but I I don't know I I it annoys me that
we don't encourage people straight after
their are levels definitely straight
after University to to to go and have a
crack or something I know you know
you've got to have the money but we we
didn't we put on a credit card yeah like
I think having a crack then is the best
way